start off this hour with Nick and
Pennsylvania hi Nick welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how are you I am
better than I deserve sir how are you
I'm doing great thank you how can I hope
to devote I was cold because I am pretty
new to to your show and to the baby
steps as a little background on the
husband and a family of five and we have
we're homeowners we have about seventy
one thousand dollars in student that's
me about nine thousand on a car and
between my wife and I our take-home pay
is about ninety four hundred dollars per
month after tax good so my question is
that my income has been a little bit
more variable lately than I'm
comfortable with and having three small
children at home I'm wondering if there
would be any reason that I should
consider switching the order of steps
two and three and the baby steps
so that I could save up they reserve
cash in the event of a potential
emergency needed for that money yeah
well sometimes people do that we have
not seen it to be successful and and
here's the reason part of what gets you
out of debt is that you're angry about
being in debt and you're scared about
being broke and that anger and that fear
drives you to extreme focus extreme
levels of sacrifice to get your butt out
how old are you I am 31 days yeah so
you've been be bopping along for about
six or seven years being normal and it's
got you seventy one thousand and nine
thousand dollars in debt and you hadn't
moved the needle that's not a bad thing
that just makes you a normal person but
what you're discovering is normal is not
really going to work for your future you
want excellence in your future and so
I'm you know I understand that when you
take it down to one thousand dollars in
savings with three kids at home that
you're gonna be really game on that
you're gonna be really focused that
you're gonna be really intense and that
that's a little scary or a lot scary
and I'm gonna use all of that fear to
cause you to bust it and anytime you get
ready to go out to eat you go now I'm
walking around with no money in the bank
and three kids I got get this stupid
debt paid off any time you get ready
talk about a vacation you're like no you
got to be kidding me I'm gonna take a
weekend trip no you got to be kidding me
and all of a sudden you're you're you
kind of start walking with a swagger
about this debt thing rather than being
in this constant financial hangover and
so that's why this is working or at
least it's my perception as to why it's
working for tens of millions of people
that we've walked with through this
process yes I understand it's scary yes
I understand over the long period of
time it's unwise but let's think about
this you got $80,000 in debt a student
loan and a car you make $140,000 a year
there is no reason in the world you
shouldn't be debt-free in 18 months but
that means you're living on beans and
rice that means you're broke friends or
think you've joined a cult your
mother-in-law is gonna think you need
counseling all this stuff because you're
gonna be game on baby
and you got the blinders on and you quit
caring about what other people think and
that's what moves the needle it's not
some kind of gyration or I'm gonna make
this comfortable don't do this the easy
way and it's just it I'm not making fun
of you I'm just telling you this those
are the things that are rattling in your
head because they rattle in my head when
I think about these things so and I
teach it so I I get it but don't do it
$1,000 baby step one baby step two is
list your death smallest to largest pay
minimum payments like your hair is on
fire on everything but the little one
and attack the little one running as if
you're running for your freakin life
because you are right now Sallie Mae and
General Motors owns your butt and I want
you to go buy your butt back get this
stuff paid off man get your life back
and that's you know that kind of that
the thing I'm putting in my voice that
I'm transferring in my spirit to you
right now speaking that that spirit of
determination over you this visceral
feeling and there's a whole lot more
part of that in getting out of debt then
there is trying to figure out an angle
or a math thing and I'm always trying to
figure out an angle or a math thing cuz
I'm a math guy but there's just there's
no shortcut to any places worth going
and bust it that's what I would tell you
to do it's a great question though as a
new listener and thank you for asking it
and thank you for letting me step up on
my preach box for a minute there and
preach because it's it's good for all of
us to be reminded what is happening here
on this show and the people that are
actually doing the things that we talk
about on this show and what's happening
folks is is that we discovered 25 years
ago after I was doing financial
counseling I would sit down with a
couple and that's all we did was
financial counseling I sit down with a
couple that was almost bankrupt
I would lay out a full game plan in
detail that all the math worked on where
they could pay their bills they could
turn it around in three months they'd be
current I would work out a deal with
their mortgage company and we're gonna
deal with their car company and they
were behind the payment and a half get
caught up and it was all laid out and
they would go home and three weeks later
they would surrender and file bankruptcy
it was all laid out I did all the math
work why didn't they do it because I
sent them home from that meeting with
the same habit patterns that they came
into that meeting with and I tried to
fix habit patterns with math and it was
really frustrating for me because our
math guy and I want to fix everything
with math and it's not a math problem if
we were doing math people we wouldn't
have credit card debt this is not a math
problem I mean who in the right freakin
mind would ever walk into a payday
lender at eight hundred and forty
percent Interest if you were doing math
it's not a math problem this is I'm
scared crapless I can't even breathe I
don't know what I'm gonna do
and so I wander into this place and I
get ripped off by one of these payday
lenders I open up a credit card and I
buy a pizza on a credit card and I'm 19
years old in college and I come out of
college with as much credit card debt as
I do student loan debt this is normal
personal finance we discovered is not a
math problem it's 80% behavior it's
person had knowledge you already know
what to do and you have to change your
behaviors and change your habits and
when you do your life will change be not
conformed to this world Roman says
Romans 12:2 one of my favs
don't be normal normal sucks be not
conformed to this world but be
transformed transform
how are you transformed the renewing of
your mind